when we begin this news out in Lithuania
and the NATO Summit there shaping the
future of the military Alliance the NATO
Chief Jan stoltenberg announced that
turkey has agreed to back Sweden's bid
to join after blocking the application
for a year now with Sweden as a member
the military Alliance confer the
bolstered forces in the Baltic Sea the
Kremlin doesn't like that Prospect
Russia says NATO expansion on its
borders is a mistake NATO leaders are
also expected to discuss membership for
Ukraine President Vladimir zielinski
says Ukraine will be ready to join when
the war ends
well let's bring in our diplomatic
editor James base who joins us now live
from Vilnius James Ian stoltenberg must
be pretty pleased about ankara's change
of art he's worked very hard is it
well they've been working non-non-stop
on this remember there were meetings
that took place at the end of last week
on Thursday in Brussels with the foreign
ministers it had to go to the leaders
and president erdogan was the man to try
and convince and of course he came up in
the final hours with a new linkage
linking the membership of Sweden with
NATO to turkey's long-stalled
application to join the European Union
but it seems that they've come up with a
deal and that Sweden can become NATO's
32nd member I have to say you just have
to put a little bit of caution there
because it did seem pretty close a year
ago Madrid that Sweden and Finland would
be able to join the alliance together
and of course it's gone on for another
year since then and it's not a done deal
until the Turkish Parliament and the
Hungarian Parliament Hungary said it
would ratify it if Turkey did until
they've actually ratified it so not a
done deal yet but I think the swedes and
other NATO countries seem pretty happy
that president erdogan has probably
taken this as far as he can
I've been saying further expansion is
also on the cards we're hearing strong
words from president zolensky to push
for that
president zielinski has been talking
tough for days and he's talking tough
again now about the situation he wants
some very clear language on an
invitation to Ukraine uh they've been
arguing for days and days and days the
ambassadors who are based in Brussels of
the of the 31 NATO countries over the
exact wording different countries had
different views on this they were
talking about the rightful place of
Ukraine in NATO and then the language
has changed Ukraine's future is with
NATO there's a various phrasings that
I've heard from various diplomats I've
spoken to for Ukraine they want one word
in there invitation invite or invitation
and it's not clear I was told by one
figure that that was now in I've been
told by others it's definitely out we
will have to see that communique
normally would be conduct would be
pre-negotiated by all the ambassadors
they pre-cooked these things so when the
leaders come it's just all for show and
to show the unity on this occasion is
gone down to the wire and although I'm
told there may well be some language
that looks agreeable in the end it'll be
those leaders who make the final
decision and if they don't like it they
themselves the 31 leaders will have to
get their pens out and start rewriting
and James this all comes at a time where
there are concerns as well about
ammunition and weapons for Ukraine from
the west where are we at on that in
terms of NATO's show of solidarity here
yeah well they they are going to say
that they're going to be security
guarantees for Ukraine there's going to
be a multi-year
um uh funding for Ukraine's war effort
but Ukraine needs things now and it
needs ammunition particularly and that's
one of the reasons that there's been
this controversy of cluster Munitions
that's something the U.S had ready to go
ready to ship but of course that's
deeply controversial when two-thirds of
NATO have signed the International
Convention the treaty that bans cluster
bombs
and that's very interesting James
because obviously there is a huge amount
of controversy within NATO itself how
much Unity is there amongst NATO members
at the moment
okay
well I mean I think if you look back on
this and the scale of this war that the
timeline of the whole War we're now 15
months in I think uh in in February last
year you would have been surprised to
have seen of this much support for
Ukraine from uh NATO and this much Unity
um when you've been going on this long
of course there are cracks that have
developed on some issues as I say the
cluster Munitions one is is a good one
and it's a difficult one for the NATO
Secretary General Jen stoltenberg asked
him about it last week and he said NATO
has no positions on cluster Munitions
it's up to the individual members but he
knows very well that the public in NATO
countries they have a position on
cluster Munitions it's deeply unpopular
and of course they've tried to have a
very clear narrative over the last 15
months which is it's Russia carrying out
war crimes Russia uh crimes of
aggression crimes against humanity and
that slightly I think using cluster
Munitions muddies that messaging that
they've been trying to sell to the
publics in all of the NATO Nations our
diplomatic James B is there covering
that Summit for us in Vilnius thank you
very much James well what is the Putin
administration's response to all of this
that's a question for Maria zacharova
the spokesperson for the Russian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs who joins us
now live from Moscow Mr carava thank you
very much for your time your foreign
minister Sergey lavrov has said that
Russia is taking appropriate And Timely
measures in response to Nato expansion
that it will protect its own legitimate
security interests what does that mean
in practice
hello I would like to start not only
with your question I would like to
comment what you published your
journalists and your commenters have
just said that nature has demonstrated
unity and cohesion with regard to
Ukraine you know which sounds like an uh
a joke what is cohesion is so NATO is
United about
Ukraine are joining that and you're
saying your article that NATO
demonstrates support for Ukraine what
support for Ukraine you can see here
because NATO decides not to include
Ukraine what support are we talking
about so it seems that Ukraine NATO
members have been calling Ukraine to in
the into the Western World at the time
when Ukraine calls for help they
abandoned the Ukraine they let Ukraine
down
you should see the reality instead of
making up stories and rather than
repeating the statements of Secretary
General stoltenberg this is the major
outcome
the major outcome is when
you stage
anti-constitutional coup d'etat in
Ukraine you are dragging Ukraine into an
armed confrontation with Russia this is
a cohesion
of unity nuts and and if we think about
the question why Ukraine is not included
in nature ranks it is quite interesting
they invite Finland
and Sweden but not Ukraine why this is a
question that should be posed all TV
channels why not
because you see multi-billion
financial aid is provided to Ukraine
through NATO it doesn't matter if
countries are doing that together or
individually
they're providing arms to Ukraine so why
not Ukraine is not a member of NATO
um Maria sorry I believe that the answer
is quite interesting there is a version
that um
I want to ask you a question off the
back of your question you ask why NATO
hasn't made Ukraine an offer of
membership there is the argument that
perhaps including Ukraine while it's at
war with Russia would then be putting
NATO at war with Russia how would Russia
view an any kind of offer of membership
or a fast track for Ukraine to join NATO
um
you truly believe that NATO is not in
the state of war against Russia because
all the fighters mercenaries military
instructors advisors many and investig
and intelligence data provided by NATO
to the key of regime NATO is involved in
the military activities certainly and
nature has been pushing Ukraine towards
that I can provide you only one proof in
the of in the six months
month before the special military
operation in summer 2021 Nature has
carried out Military exercises in the
sea in the vicinity of the Russian
borders and they and at that time they
have decided to penetrate the Russian
border it was a six months before the
special military operation was launched
this was just one of the million
examples when the nature is involved in
the Ukrainian developments before the
hot phase of the conflict I have just
another proposal for you let's address
another answer to the question why
nature is not including Ukraine probably
you would like this answer more maybe
because the western part of Ukraine in
terms of
Poland should belong to Poland
and
and this topic has only uh
starring for Poland
Ukraine
is not needed in nato in that
composition and there is you know
obvious
desire of Fallen to invade the western
part of Ukraine this is why Ukraine is
not invited to Nato because if Ukraine
becomes part of NATO NATO members
themselves should recognize borders of
Ukraine and NATO members are not
interested in that because prevalence
Poland is interested in the western part
of Ukraine mizakarovar I want to to
clarify a point does Russia right now as
you alluded to there currently believe
that it is at war with NATO
is involved certainly in the
confrontation with Russia and I'm quite
surprised that you're asking this
question we've been talking about this
every day that with regard to Russia
they have launched a hybrid War hybrid
War men's military confrontation
sanctions pressure
political pressure against Russia we're
talking about this every day that was
mentioned by our president by our
Minister we've been talking about it for
days that nature is involved in military
actions against Russia and as for
Ukraine there is no Russia Ukraine
conflict it does not exist because
Ukraine is used by Nature first and
foremost by the United States and Great
Britain as an instrument as leverage to
influence Russia well one of the
purposes of Russia's special military
operation in Ukraine was ostensibly to
stop NATO from getting more of a
foothold there but it really seems to
have done quite the opposite how did
that happen
not
[Music]
we had we hadn't an objective to weaken
NATO because nature United States Great
Britain and the entire native had an
objective to weaken Russia just look at
their statements for years they were
talking about the Russia's deterrence
they wanted to weaken our country but
they haven't made any statements we
hadn't pursued a policy to weaken nature
we had an objective
that was was set for the entire country
which is to demossify the key of regime
because key regime is Nazis criminal and
the terrorist regime and we have set an
objective to the nazify the Reiki regime
and the second objective was to
demilitate the key regime and we have a
global objective which is to ensure
guarantees for security guarantees for
Russia I will recall that six months
before the launch of the special
military operation our country offered
the so-called Collective West we're
talking about the which includes the
United States NATO and members of the
osce to develop a new security
guarantees that will truly
convince all of us that we have peaceful
intentions we have all peaceful
intentions and we would denied they have
made we have
provided this security guarantees in
written but they refuse to discuss this
since we were refused to discuss the
security guarantees that then
we're going to create our security
guarantees on our own well speaking of
security guarantees Mr Caravan you said
that you would tell us a little bit more
about what your foreign minister Sergey
lavrov meant when he said that in
response to Nato expansion it would
protect its own legitimate security
interests what does that look like
[Applause]
this is the creation of security
guarantees on the ground and ask for the
political dimension of that question I
will explain what uh the conceptual
differences in the political positions
of the West and our country well
Western countries believe that they have
a moral right to
ensure their political dominance in the
world and first and foremost we're
talking about Washington that through
their exclusiveness they have a historic
right to dictate their will and they
have established when the term
rules-based World Order
but there are no rules nobody has
devised these rules nobody has developed
these rules uh no one is aware of what
these rules are about and our
understanding of the security matters
and security guarantees is based on the
understanding of international law which
includes the U.N Charter
the entire
package
uh that of documents are developed by
the year and Security Council this is
how we're understanding of how peace
should be built it should be it how the
world should be built it shouldn't be
based on the rules that no one is aware
of it should be based in international
law at the heart of which the global
Universal concept of sovereignty
Independence and Sovereign equality of
states
there are no states that are better
worse stronger
or maybe because of the economic power
can have some additional rights who can
have influence and Lord with other
states there is an equality of states
that is enshrined in the U.N Charter
this is one of the fundamental elements
of understanding security guarantees
apart from establishing right now the
relevant security guarantees on the
ground well then let me ask you what is
moscow's vision of a future security
architecture for Europe what would that
look like what would you propose
I have just talked about it and I can
repeat we proceed from the assumption
that now the entire world is should make
a choice
do we want to live um in the cold in the
conditions where all countries are equal
then we should opt for international law
that has been established by
International institutions through
consensus session International
institutions like United Nations and its
Security Council or we should opt for
near Colonial times and turn it colonial
times and turn it all into the near
Colonial world that is pushed forward by
the United States Great Britain and
their NATO satellite countries which is
the first option which is the
international legal
fundamentals of our world of our
International affairs with the equal
rights of each and every state with the
equal world with an opportunity for each
and every state to pursue their own
independent foreign policy and their
independent domestic policy without
internal without um
interference from the outside
based on the U.N Charter and
international law United Nations could
become part of the system that you're
talking about Mr carava you spoke there
about international law many countries
regard your special military operation
in Ukraine as having broken
international law what would it take for
Russia to bring its special military
operation there to an end
foreign
and I agree with those who say that
international law is violated in Ukraine
I truly support this statement it is
absolutely true but the question is when
the international law was violated
it was violated in 2014 when in the
center of Ukraine in the Ukrainian
capital and the Maiden in Kiev they have
carried out an unconstitutional coup
d'etat it's not because the Ukrainian
people rised against their authorities
but the Americans but the United States
Great Britain France Germany Poland and
Baltic States United to house to
Ukrainian authorities and to
bring to power with those who they
support So when they have ousted when
they have overthrown janakovich the
actual president of Ukraine and where
they have provided authority to the
citizens of the United States Canada
Germany and many other states it's at
that point when the international law
was violated at that time we should have
talked about it and we have been talking
about it for all this almost 10 years
and unfortunately the West didn't want
to talk about it and they didn't want to
talk about it because everyone would
learn the truth of what idologists are
doing in Washington Maria zakara over
there the spokesperson for the Russian
Ministry of Foreign Affairs thank you
very much for your time and for joining
us here on Al Jazeera
well let's bring in our diplomatic
editor James bays in Vilnius he's been
listening in to James what did you make
of what Ms zakarova had to say there
well a bit of a split screen moment
because while she was speaking saying
those things the actual NATO leaders are
now in the hall the north North Atlantic
Council that is the leaders meeting they
that meeting just started while she was
speaking to us there
um very interesting to hear what she had
to say because it is completely the
opposite way around from everything that
you hear from NATO and the NATO leaders
she described the coup in sorry to
describe the invasion in Russia and what
has happened in Ukraine as an
anti-constitutional by NATO and she kept
referring to the United Nations in
international order while you look at
the UN Charter and the most basic thing
that Charter which is the founding
document of international law since the
second world war the most basic thing it
says if you're a country you're not
allowed to invade another country and
that clearly is what Russia dud did in
in in March last year let's discuss all
this further I'm joined by Mikhail
baranovski he's the managing director of
the German Marshall fund you were
listening to Maria zacharova what did
you make of her comments well frankly
it's a little bit hard to follow someone
who has a very loose connection with the
truth and with reality that starts
um it's Point number one secondly I'm
I'm really glad to hear that she's such
a fan of uh United Nations and the U.N
Charter as you said it's very clear and
it was confirmed by over 140 countries
in the U.N assembly that Russia has
committed an act of aggression and has
attacked Ukraine against breaking this
this Charter so I very much would hope
that Russia would follow the
international
and as a founder of United Nations
should follow the U.N Charter and stop
the illegal War again well that was a
very interesting argument in there that
that NATO was weak and disunified and
that was because they were not making
Ukraine a member I thought that's the
one thing Russia didn't want I she for
for a while she sounded like one of the
biggest supporter of NATO a membership
for for Ukraine of course this is this
is again twisting twisting the the
arguments arguments around Russia I
think is trying to mask the fact that
it's doing very badly against a country
that is much smaller and much less
populous you know we used to think that
Russian army was the second best in the
world we now know it's the second best
in Ukraine because Ukraine is is able to
withhold its attack let me put you two
points that maybe have some validity
NATO is very very involved in this war
not just the arms and ammunition but she
talked about the the trainers the
instructors they're not probably boots
on the ground in terms of of of NATO
forces but NATO's really enmeshed in
this isn't it there are no boots on the
ground as you said one of the principles
of the U.N Charter is that country that
is attacked has a way and has a right to
self-defense and other countries that
can support this country in self-defense
so this is what NATO member states
because not Minato as an organization is
doing both in military aid in terms of
training that's very much clear because
again this is such a blatant violation
of the basic principles of international
law and the U.N Charter and the other
area where she she spoke which which we
mentioned a moment ago is disunity but
there is a little bit of disunity on
show at this Summit it took some time to
persuade president erdema erdogan about
Sweden 15 months and we're not entirely
sure yet uh whether the Turkish
Parliament and then the Hungarian
Parliament will finally ratify Sweden's
membership to become the 32nd uh member
so there's that issue and then president
zabinski's got big asks here and there's
real disagreement isn't there I mean
they they've been trying to solve these
disagreements at ambassadorial level for
days they haven't managed it in fact the
leaders have now gone to the close part
of their meeting they are actually going
to pour over the text and maybe rewrite
it themselves well you know look we are
democracies democracies uh have to find
a consensus and we are just having a
healthy debate especially around the
issue of how do we phrase The Next Step
uh the next steps of Ukraine's
relationship with NATO let's remember
that in Bucharest NATO has agreed read
that eventually Ukraine will be no
matter what will be part of the alliance
we are now have agreed as Alliance that
there will be NATO Ukraine Council that
there will be a military aid going to
Ukraine and that the procedure of
joining for Ukraine will be easier but
what's not clear is how and when there
will be a new invitation and yes we are
having a healthy debate about this I see
a lot of unity because on key issues
that Ukraine will be in NATO also that
NATO will be strengthened and that's the
that's the regional plans that will be
decided and in fact I'm not I'm relaxed
about Sweden joining the alliance we
have a total Unity of the of the
alliance and I do agree here with
stoltenberg who said look this Summit is
already historic before it started
because Sweden is joining so if you're a
NATO leader right now yes what should
you be most worried about about the war
in Ukraine right now
I would be most worried about the
ability of Ukraine to continue this
bloody war about its population about
the fact that this is in the end very
unfair fight and that's why that's why
the leaders will continue to on one hand
quarrel about the language but on the
other hand like France's president
macron will will offer additional
military aid I'm concerned about
Shifting the calculus of the Kremlin of
putting specifically that the time is
working not for Russia but for Ukraine
and I think we are seeing this with
progressing smoothie Mutiny that if he
continues to do to attack Ukraine there
will be consequences for Russia
internally and I hope that will in the
west continue the military aid as long
as it takes for Russia to become and
what about the U.S we have elections in
November next year yes I mean that could
if Trump was re-elected for example
um or someone like Trump who has views
on Ukraine that perhaps does not want to
be involved in the Long Haul Europe's
not going to fight or help the Ukraine
fight this war on its own is it you know
it's true that we have elections in uh
well we actually have elections in
Russia as well because I wanted to say
in all democracies uh the future of
Western support will certainly depend a
lot on what happens in the United States
when I talk with my Republican friends
they assure me that the Republican party
is very supportive of Ukraine you know
it's one thing to be saying uh very
strong words in the campaign let's see
if first of all let's see who wins and
then let's see how the next president
governs because this is clear really in
the interest of the United States and of
NATO to have stability and peace in
Europe and that includes
having Russia back behind its borders
and withdrawing from Ukraine Michael
baranowsky of the German martial fund
thank you very much for joining us here
on Al Jazeera so the NATO Summit
formally underway now those NATO leaders
have been round the table of the North
Atlantic Council that's what it's called
when all 31 countries meet together
sometimes it's ambassadors around the
table sometimes foreign ministers
sometimes defense ministers once a year
it is the leaders and they are now
trying to work out exactly what they're
going to see say and what their Position
will be with regard to Ukraine's
aspirations to be a member of the
alliance our diplomatic editor James Bay
is there at that
thank you so much James